[Music]
now when i think of omelette i think of
breakfast but this is an omelette like
no other because
we are at marshall point lighthouse i'm
gonna give you a main lobster
omelet um done with a little bit of heat
but more importantly something we can
have for lunch or dinner not just
breakfast okay let's start off with some
red onion why red onion over white onion
the red onion gives it a lot more
sweetness less harsh
and the secret here is to sort of
lightly caramelize
the onion
and it just gives a lot more sweetness
to that lobster
okay
a beautiful chili okay i want it quite
spicy the nice thing about this lobster
is that it can take
a lot of heat because of the sweetness
again i'm not going to super find the
chili just seeds in as well for the heat
and the garlic no raw flavor
sliced and then from there
i've got the most amazing handmade
butter
this butter has been laced with the most
amazing seaweed that actually smells of
truffle so i don't want it burning so
here's the secret
a little teaspoon of olive oil in there
just a touch
then in with your butter copious amounts
of butter for these reasons
now
that water is the seaweed okay
from there
fry off those onions
garlic
and lot
in
in they go
and that is beautiful
now
get sweating
from there
leave the lobster
quite chunky i want to taste the lobster
across the omelette so don't go too
small
i've got the knuckles the claws a little
bit of tail
okay go too small the lobster becomes
rubbery so from there in
and start rolling that lobster through
there
so we're going to lightly saute
this lobster
through those beautiful
onions
now
give that a really nice toss you can see
those beautiful colors in there the
secret here is to gently cook this now
okay
beautiful
cook this too aggressively and the
lobster will go really rubbery it's a
main lobster so incredibly sweet and
this time of the year of course the
shells are a little bit softer we're
coming out of summer going into fall
but lightly
just saute that lobster now we've got
the heat in there
one final ingredient
take your beautiful heirloom tomatoes
and just slice them in half
look how juicy they are
add them in
that's going to make this really nice
and sweet
okay
that sweetens up the lobster meat
and the nice thing about this you can
make this literally
in the morning let it rest and then when
you add the eggs you just add a spoon at
a time to make this incredible lobster
omelet
taste
delicious
take that out
beautiful
i'm gonna put a few chives in there
literally to give that really nice light
flavor just want a really nice
fresh
feel to that lobster
got the sweetness of the tomatoes the
heat with the chili
the garlic
in with the chives
and then just gently mix that over
now for the eggs
lightly crack the eggs on a flat surface
in i'm gonna do
a
beautiful
five egg omelet because this can be done
for two or three guests
once you've got a filling as sumptuous
as that you don't need that much egg you
need
more lobster give it a light little
whisk
across that i'm going to just drop in
little touches of my
beautiful butter hand churned seaweed
butter just to give it a little bit of
saltiness in there
and this is where you've got to be quick
now this is where it all happens so
quickly
so eggs in
beautiful
now
work those eggs really important we
scoop down every time and work
now the secret behind this omelette for
me is to keep it nice and sort of creamy
and there's a way of doing that without
overcooking the eggs i'll show you
once you get that base the eggs are
cooked flatten it out like that now
and then from there i'm going to start
placing my lobster
in the middle
lobster's cooked
got a beautiful tomato
i want that nice beautiful
sweet
rich flavor in the middle of my omelette
and then from there
i'm gonna take
a little pinch
of my mascarpone so when we fold this
i've got the heat
coming off
and so
you'll think the eggs are undercooked
the eggs aren't undercooked the
mascarpone cheese just gives that really
nice
beautiful
incredible flavor
now for the magic
come back over
from there lightly season that
and then get your lemon
and zest that inside and that mascarpone
cheese i'm telling you
gives the omelet
the most amazing
tap the bottom of the pan and start
folding now
over
that side there
and the bottom over
and lock in all that beautiful flavor
roll it to the end
don't worry you're not going to
spill it get your plate and literally
fold it over
and there we have
the most amazing main lobster omelet
finish with a touch of mascara and
cheese to give that nice richness in the
center
check this out
oh boy
now if you enjoyed that recipe please
click the link below and if you missed
uncharted then please watch it on catch
up on disney plus
[Music]